morgan is safely a sconce on his luxury
yacht but meghan markle has decided to
produce some of her finest work i reckon
she does it to wind him up you know
morgan's on holiday let's make the old
man choke on his fresh oysters on a
serious note in the week when we should
all be focusing on princess diana and
her incredible legacy 25 years on the
global media instead reporting megan
comparing her marriage is unbelievable
to nelson mandela's release from jail
now today mandela's own grandson slammed
markle for equating the culmination of
nearly 350 years of struggle with the
celebration of her wedding and if that
wouldn't have got morgan heaving
overboard this afternoon this is just
ridiculous a new episode of megan's
podcast archetypes dropped with special
great guest mariah carey here's a teaser
with a warning hope you're not in the
middle of your dinner
if there's any time in my life that it's
been more focused on my race it's only
once i started dating my husband then i
started to understand what it was like
to be treated like a black woman because
up until then i had been treated like a
mixed woman
i'm now joined by royal commentator and
biographer angela levin talk tv
commentator afia hagan and royal expert
from the u.s kinsey scofield ladies
welcome um
let's start with my friend angela levin
is it me or the majority of the british
people that are wrong what is this woman
up to what is her motivation for
continually it seems drawing attention
to herself whilst kicking the very
institution that that has been
long before her and will last long after
i don't i don't get it
well i think it's quite simple
actually and it's not just the uk
it's happening all around the world of
people who are seeing right through her
i think her aim is to get rid of the
british royal family without a doubt
and part of that is because she has to
win
she fights and fights and goes on and on
until she wins wins what well she wins
her battle she didn't think she was well
treated there in fact what it was of
course was that she wasn't used to it
you can't change your country change
your family change your job come into
something that's very unusual and decide
within five minutes you want to make
them modern and they should listen to
you and she should be number one they
should make her very very famous and
concentrate on all her beauty and her
brain and all the rest of it
without giving anything a chance if she
stayed there it might have been helpful
and had been sensible and fitted in but
she won't because she wants everything
her way all the time um if i could bring
in kinsey schofield from america thank
you so much for joining us kinsey um the
americans are famous for loving the
royal family and i don't even know i did
that accent um just explain to me when
when this i mean the new york post today
toddler and tiara has made it pretty
clear what they think of this woman
are american people's views of her
changing are they supportive because
today she's played the race card again
i do think that they've changed because
america is really struggling right now
with inflation gas prices politics i
mean everything is so polarizing so when
meghan markle sitting in her mansion
goes on tv to complain about the you
know becoming a princess and having all
of this attention and this platform
given to her by her in-laws i do think
that perception is changing in america
and we're a little bit more critical of
her after the oprah interview we all
sympathized with her we wanted to take
them in we wanted to protect them but we
talked about that a year ago there's no
reason to continue on with that story
what does she have to say what is what
are her morals what are her values and
what are her objectives we need more
from megan than continuing to obsess
over the past i completely agree i fear
hagen um i know that you see it
differently i appreciate you being on
the show what i don't get about meghan
markle is are we saying that she didn't
realize what she was marrying into she
seems very
uh to me to to be dead set on this
course of destroying in her mind the
royal family she seems to have a very
high opinion of herself and and if you
as angela said you judge the global
reaction to this
there's real anger
real anger i think that's faux anger to
be honest i think actually
what angela said was right she wasn't
used to it absolutely she's changed jobs
she's just got married she's had these
huge life changes uh marrying into the
royal family it was a huge thing for her
but she always wanted that did she
always wanted that she was outside
buckingham palace eyeing up the royal
family years and years ago do you not go
with the people who say she had this
completely laid out this is a plan to
get with this boy who's had all sorts of
issues and has as we all know had
problems right i mean prince harry right
now in the united i mean i was watching
something today they were saying these
two should be stripped of their titles
and and sent away how can you still
trade on something that you spend almost
every day slagging off that's what i
don't get look meghan markle is talking
about her experiences when you talk
about playing the race card that's
unfair because there is no such thing as
playing the race card she as a
mixed-race woman is talking about her
experiences which affects her every day
unfortunately you can't choose that so
it's not playing a role right okay we
know each other but no no no no no it's
about talking about her right it's about
her experience kinsley finished so i'm
going to finish as well it's about
talking about her experiences as
you asked do i think that she planned
every moment of this no i don't i don't
i really really don't know
all right she has that much free time
what do you think there's a lot of
people who spend a lot of time reading
between the lines where there is nothing
to read she gave an interview
and the headlines were extrapolated from
that so it's nonsense to say that she's
been absolutely ghastly her time has
been totally inappropriate when harry's
grandfather was dying in hospital and
she knew and harry knew they'd been told
she had two weeks or three weeks to live
she still went and talked on oprah
winfrey show that is disgraceful to
upset him and upset the queen what her
father was doing i agree so let me you
say i said about the race thing and if
there is any form of racism you know me
we've known each other a long time in
any part of the world disgusting and
wrong but here's what i get
she's that upper own i'm sorry i'm going
to say it backside she has the temerity
to say that my wedding to a prince and i
take kinsey's view in the middle of a
global economic recession where families
are struggling she says and i quote me
getting married i was told it was as
important as nelson mandela his grandson
today says who the hell does she think
she is come on that's again we also need
to talk about the way this feature was
written and the way that a lot of these
quotes have been done angela i let you
finish so i'm going to finish as well a
lot of these quotes have been
extrapolated for their own kind of
generating their headlines what she said
was a cast member of the lion king said
to her
she is not comparing herself to nelson
mandela mention it
why mention it member of the lion king
said to her that this moment in time was
like that she's not comparing herself to
nelson mandela
if you read the next line it says she
knows that she's known nelson mandela
okay let's bring in she's not going to
let's bring her to that let's bring
kinsey back in from the u.s desperate to
speak kenzie oh i'm so sorry i but i i
just have to stress meghan markle is a
savvy woman she has gone through press
training she's gone through royal press
training this is a woman that knows how
important sound bites are the writer
even acknowledges that she speaks as if
there's a bachelor producer living in
her head she knows what these reporters
are going to take away and turn into
headlines she knows the talking points
and quite frankly she is so important in
the united states that she could say
this is off limits and this is off
limits megan knows exactly what she's
saying and what she's doing i think the
woman is very intelligent so i think
it's silly for us to say oh she had no
idea that people were going to pull
certain headlines she is very skilled
and very savvy and was probably some pr
guru in another life
conniving well can i just say all of us
would agree and this is what really
winds me up of fear right
tomorrow is 25 years
since the princess diana died okay the
tragedy that rocked the world right her
two sons left without a mother you
cannot convince me we could sit here all
night and say that yet again meghan
markle's timing don't tell me it's a
coincidence she wants the world to be
talking about her instead of diana
that's her problem that is it she sees
herself as diana number two she sees
herself as an alternative donna she
wears diana's perfume when she was with
harry she was saying that all sorts of
things that she's very close to diana
harry said he thought his mother would
they would be best friends i mean she's
planning herself to be another diana
because she thinks she's like her
because she also felt that she was
treated badly of course she wasn't it
was a whole different sort of i would
love to know and she and she loved the
royal family but she couldn't help with
it i would love to know a few yeah you
can but can i just say this i would love
to know what diana princess of wales
would have made it michael i agree with
you yes sofia your shirt i can answer no
thanks angela you know i think it's
really disappointing actually that this
has all happened around this time
because i would love to be talking to
you more about diana's legacy about 25
years since she passed about where we
all were when it happened yeah about you
know she was a fashion icon she was an
icon of philanthropy yeah about the
legacy she leaves but you're saying i
think you just made
why has it happened because meghan
markle has let it out now and you cannot
affair with the greatest of respect
she is savvy kinsey's right she knows
what she's doing she has released this
the cut and that ridiculous podcast to
however much millions she's paid for
that on the eve of the death of his
mother and i am astounded that prince
harry does not have a pair big enough to
say i love that was my mother come on
but he's got no courage to say anything
against her he will lie because um he
doesn't want to upset her she will just
let her do everything and she's made a
total wreck of him i spent a year and a
quarter with him hang on the second if i
if you could i spent a year and a
quarter with him and he's totally
changed
he's just become resentful and
aggressive and he's he's taught him how
to hate his family he got on very well
with prince charles they had their
problems earlier on later on they were
very compatible and she's just destroyed
him and i think he's up a terrible
terrible situation at the moment at the
end of the day he's a grown man she's a
grown woman they're a married couple i'm
pretty sure that they had discussions
around the timing of the release of the
podcast you know and
you don't know that angela because
you're not
married to the question do you not think
the fact that it was released on the on
the anniversary almost that the eve of
the anniversary of princess diana's
death shows complete disrespect and
absolutely nails in most people's minds
what a manipulative woman meghan markle
is i have to say that when it comes to
meghan markle she cannot do right for
doing wrong then shut up and don't say
anything whenever she releases this
podcast would be the wrong time whenever
she gave the interview
or any other magazine would be the
reviews all right let me just say
the queen is so ill i agree 96 but why
do it an upset
here's what i don't get kinsey if i
could bring you back in i've said this
from day one since they went to
california my old man worked for the
royal family i have a strong affiliation
but i'm also intelligent enough to know
there are two sides when they both said
and i quote and i've said this to you
before of fear we don't want anything to
do with the royal family we want to go i
went you know what fair play go to
california have your life happy kids but
when you get on a plane saying the press
intrusion is disgusting and the minute
you land you sign a 112 million deal
with spotify when anything you do is
actually a dig at the royal family and
your timing is seemingly always
fantastic no wonder people in this
country and across the world are cynical
i mean i can't argue with you prince
harry and meghan markle have an
incredible platform prince harry could
be branded as a
zuckerberg or a barack obama a thought
leader not i'm not saying he's going to
be a president but he could be a thought
leader but if they are obsessed with
their past and they can't move forward
and they don't have any original ideas
all they're doing is hindering
themselves they have got to stop
attacking the british royal family and
they have got to find their own identity
i actually think that's what they're
trying to do you know when megan's
talking once when she's let's take the
podcast archetypes was she talking about
the different words that are used
against women and yes she does talk
about her own experiences but she's
talking about new topics as well you
know serena williams retiring she's
going to talk about producing television
and films with issa rae amid de kaling i
think yes that is one way of them moving
forward and moving forward from the past
and actually do agree with kinsey that
they need to do that that they need to
project attacking the people
look i think when it comes to them
attacking the royal family there's lots
of people that will read between the
lines where there's no lines to be read
between and will extrapolate the
headlines that they want to generate the
case
the newspapers that they want a fear if
that's the case you will not convince me
that she doesn't know that people will
read between the lines that she doesn't
know that every time she opens her mouth
she's going to get a reaction
when she talks about the royal family if
she talks about the royal family then
it's oh my goodness how dare she talk
about the royal family we'll talk about
it
if she doesn't talk about the royal
family why would she not reference the
royal family at all at the end of the
day it's literally this simple meghan
markle and harry cannot do right for
doing wrong that's their own fault final
word from
when they left the royal family they had
everything they wanted they had a big
house they had lots of money coming in
they then had two children one of each
they were so happy 16 toilets mandela
didn't have one in his 27 years of being
in prison um and they should be happy
but they're they're full of bile and
nastiness i i will horror i will
appreciate everybody's opinion affair
yours certainly kinses yours angela as
well i think what's really interesting
about the british people um the british
people in fact that the people across
the world will make their own minds up
for me yes of course she has a platform
and yes of course she has a right to
talk but i will not be changing my mind
that the timing the timing of meghan
markle's outburst via pod